[Music]
so over the past few days I've embarked
on a journey to see some of the smaller
lesser-known releases that you guys have
been requesting me to review for about a
month or two now and the first one on my
list was Calvary starring Brendan
Gleeson what this movies about is a
priest who's in Ireland and he's
surrounded by doubt everyone in this
small community that he lives in is
constantly talking to him about the fact
that they just don't get it anymore life
is going in a weird place
they don't understand finances they
don't understand religion they don't
understand politics and the movie is
basically seen two scenes of him
visiting various people talking to them
and figuring out what their problems are
and it's sort of like therapy sessions
between him and other people who live in
this town but the main plot of the movie
revolves around the fact that in the
opening scene he receives a death threat
by someone when they're going to confess
to him and so throughout the movie you
are wondering who that person is and as
he visits from person to person you're
trying to figure out is it him is it her
who is it there are certain movies
throughout the year that I think really
need time to sink in movies that you
really need time to mull over in your
head a little bit and figure out what
was going on and think about it and
dissect it a lot sometimes I think it's
really bad to immediately review a film
as soon as you see it a lot of times
people ask me like it while I'm at the
screening what'd you think of it I'm
like just let me think about it a little
bit I need to let it sink in because
sometimes giving an immediate reaction
isn't really the best idea and this is
definitely one of those movies and I'm
really glad that I gave this about a 24
hour period to really sit and think
about this movie and some of its themes
and some of its subject matter because
this script is very very impressive
because it goes in a lot of different
places and it really delves deep into a
lot of very mature themes about the way
people view sex politics religion and
simple relationships amongst other
people and this film really goes into
some of these themes in a very deep very
mature way and sometimes with actually a
lot of humor it also looks really
terrific this is a really good-looking
movie I mean it looks way more expensive
than it was and I got to say by far the
most impressive part of this movie is
Brendan Gleeson this guy is a master
class actor he doesn't even seem like an
actor he's just reading lines and they
feel so incredibly
real all at once on his face you can
read so many different things sadness
regret happiness empathy he's just he's
so good at embodying that priest-like
image where you're not supposed to
really show too much of your emotions
because of his dark past that you
learned more about in the movie it
becomes increasingly harder for him to
hide some of those emotions and that's
when the film really picks up that being
said this film can be a little slow at
times and there are a lot of discussions
with certain characters that in the end
just come off as kind of a scene that
might be there to make you think that
person might be the guy that threatened
them you know like in the end there are
certain scenes that don't really feel as
if there are necessary certain
characters that feel like they could be
removed they just feel like they are
characters to give you another person to
be skeptical about you know what I mean
and that is probably my biggest flaw of
this movie because there are times
throughout the film where you're like
where is this really going it's not
really until like the second act where
you realize it really is just him having
conversations with people that's one of
the aspects of this film that took a
while for me to grasp and once I
realized what the film is trying to do
it opened up my eyes and I was like okay
this is really cool Calvary is a great
looking film with a fantastic script and
amazing acting especially by Brendan
Gleeson definitely check this movie out
if you are a fan of some of these
smaller films or if you want to learn
more about just conversation pieces I'm
gonna give Calvary a B+ guys thank you
so much as always for watching if you've
seen this movie I'm interested in
knowing what your thoughts are below and
as always thank you and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
by nice
[Music]
Oh